good morning hank it's tuesday and here
i am making a vlogbrothers video which
i've been doing for almost 15 years i
was making vlogbrothers videos during
the george w bush administration i was
making them before the iphone existed i
was making them before i had children
one of whom is now in sixth grade pretty
much whatever's happening if it's
tuesday i try to make a video like i've
made videos on tuesdays when i couldn't
get my eyes to focus due to
labyrinthitis and i made one in a hotel
room just after my grandfather's funeral
i also make them on good days like hank
if i had to cite the single best day of
my professional life so far it was
january 10 2013 when you and i and kimya
dawson and the mountain goats and neil
gaiman and other people played carnegie
hall and my friends and family were
there and i uploaded a video that
morning now i know i don't have to do it
this way but i like to and here's why
the thing is this 15 years of
consistency is notable for me because i
am the worst at consistency like i've
heard about people who write novels by
sitting down at the same desk at the
same time seven days a week writing for
the same number of hours i've never been
able to write every day sometimes i
write at night usually i squeeze in
writing between other things between
video shoots or meetings even before i
was a youtuber though i was wildly
inconsistent with my writing like i
wrote parts of my first novel looking
for alaska on lunch breaks and part of
it on weekends and sometimes i would
write it like in the margin of whatever
book i was reading i would write for
like six weeks every night and then for
two weeks i wouldn't write it all
because i don't know i wanted to play
fifa 2002. there's only been one period
of my life when i was like a full-time
professional writer the latter half of
2006 just after my book in abundance of
catharines came out i decided to quit my
day job and i had endless hours to
devote to writing whereupon i learned
that i was still a wildly inconsistent
writer and that the days were a little
bit terrifying in their emptiness and so
three months after quitting my day job i
decided to invent a new one albeit of
the unpaid variety this youtube channel
even though there was no monetization
for creators in those days i treated
vlogbrothers as a job because it had the
contours of a job a certain amount of
work due at certain times i suppose when
writing a book there are also deadlines
but if you miss them nothing happens
whereas if i missed a vlogbrothers
deadline i might have to eat a
blenderized happy meal but more than
that i felt like people were waiting for
the video and i think that's why i've
been able to be mostly consistent over
the last 15 years because i felt like
people were counting on me i don't labor
under the delusion that vlogbrothers is
particularly important but i think that
is important having people who are
counting on you and trying to deliver
for them like at its core that's what
parenting is that's what most
relationships are that's what most jobs
are there's also another big benefit to
consistency whenever i'm asked about
writing or whatever the question i get
the most is where do you get your ideas
and i i have no idea where ideas come
from i don't know how thought works what
i do know is if i try to hold on to my
ideas i never get new ones like you
would think that after making a thousand
of these i would have long ago run out
of ideas but what actually happens is
that the more videos i make the more
ideas i get now i cannot in good
conscience recommend making a video
every tuesday for 15 years like some
days i have made videos when i probably
shouldn't have and of course many days i
have made videos that were bad and worst
of all i've made some videos that might
have been pretty good by wednesday but
were a little undercooked on tuesday but
nonetheless got uploaded but taken as a
whole making videos on a schedule helps
me to feel a sense of orientation and
community which is hugely valuable to me
even when i'm feeling sad or scared or
overwhelmed in fact it's most valuable
to me when i'm feeling sad or scared or
overwhelmed so thanks for being here it
means a lot to me hank i will see you on
friday and you will see me on tuesday
and long may it continue with occasional
vacation days of course